la vérité peut-elle encore apparaître 25
ans après les faits en arrivant au
tribunal
le frère et la mère de stéphane dietrich
ont déjà la réponse
publiquement il n'attend de rien de
celui qui a tué stéphane de 11 coups de
couteau et qui a laissé les enquêteurs
erré pendant presque vingt ans il a
monté toute sa vie va continuer à nous
balader il a baladés des enquêteurs des
fins limiers continuera de le faire ce
procès j'attends rien de particulier du
procès j'attends simplement que un jury
populaire soit sensible au fait
quelqu'un de très dangereux dans le box
des accusés christophe blain cheveux
grisonnants
un homme de 50 ans désormais rattrapé
par cet assassinat commis dans sa
jeunesse il est incarcéré depuis trois
ans depuis ses aveux répétés devant la
cour aujourd'hui encore pour son avocat
cette cour d'assises est un soulagement
christophe blain est resté trop
longtemps prisonnier de son mensonge
pendant près de 25 ans depuis 94
chaque sirènes de poppy de pompiers de
police chaque sonnette à sa porte
c'était pour lui la crainte de la
survenance des policiers et oxyde il a
pendant quinze jours au moins je suis
certain qu'on va me laisser tranquille
et que la police va paris vers 6h du
matin on est dans cet état d'esprit là
la famille de stéphane dietrich a
toujours soupçonné christophe blain et
soutient la thèse d'un crime crapuleux
blain aurait tué par jalousie pour de
l'argent stéphane était brillant a visé
dans sa gestion financière tout le
contraire de son meurtrier
reste l'autre hypothèse toujours refusée
par la famille dietrich celle d'une
relation homosexuelle entre les deux
hommes un élément clé déjà débattu
aujourd'hui il a toujours été un menteur
et continueront
la justice a retenu la préméditation
contre christophe blain sur deux fait
limpide il a acheté un couteau dans une
ville voisine pour ne pas éveiller les
soupçons
il a choisi le lieu du crime un bois
isolée près de belfort
christophe blain dit et répète qu'il ne
voulait pas tuer jamais qu'il voulait
simplement faire peur et se libérer
d'une relation imposée par stéphane
dietrich
pour ces faits ils encourent une peine
de prison à perpétuité